scusa di enìa
ho potuto fare il vestito rosso nel
cimino non ha capito dimessi dal titolo
adorati camerino lo trovi fondata da ciò
che dà su date non potete entrare in due
in camerino asset in gran bene allora
passati pure per una cosa per favore non
meri appendete le cose nelle cruz e
perché poi ci piace il casinò anzi fate
una cosa ha buttate pure che city per
terra e staccato i taccheggi se volete
perché tanto puliscono malta settimana
quindi non se ne accorge nessuno
no ma fidati care in si porta a
licenziare c è diventata lavoro e
spencer i bottini e pantaloni senza la
camicia di flanella senza una bandana
cavolo lo sai benissimo che per lavorare
dei versetti un certo modo e non siamo
mica ad h m a e cara mancano 2 euro per
poter cambiare questa sì perché sono 12
99 guarda lì dietro ci sono un sacco di
cosina 2 euro
c'è capito c'è il porto momenti però de
rosa rilassi ciclo che si illuminano al
buio o il caprino scritta atleta bassa
brava cara anch'io avrei scelto questi
comandi alla prossima